hmm
okay
so
good
good morning we're on the record this is
division four of the boulder district
court i'm judge thomas maldo
before we call the elissa matter for
those who are observing
on webex i need to ask you to please
turn off your camera
and make your microphone you need to
inform you that no person should
broadcast record or take
screen grabs of today's proceedings via
webex unless they have been expressly
granted permission to do so
under an order authorizing expanded
media coverage
any person violates disorderly direct
contempt of a court order may be
prosecuted for criminal violations we'll
call
case 21cr 487. people of the state of
colorado versus ahmad
al-aliwi alissa can i have the
appearance of counsel for the people
please
good morning honor michael doherty and
ken kufner on behalf of the people of
the state of colorado good morning
and for the defendant the more than your
honor catherine harold
daniel king and sam john on behalf of mr
alisa who needs presents
good morning council good morning mr
alisa sir you're here for an advisement
hearing i need to advise you of your
rights pursuant to rule 5.
you need to understand that you need to
make no statements and any statement
that you do make
can and may be used against you you have
the right to counsel
in this case the office of the public
defender has been appointed to represent
you any plea that you make
must be voluntary and cannot be the
result of undue influence or coercion
you have the right to bail if the
offense is available right now you're
being held without bail
mr dougherty do the people anticipate
seeking the determination that the proof
is evident the production is great
yes sean thank you mr alisa what that
means is you'll be held without bail
until such time as the court is able to
determine whether or not the proof is
evident and the presumption is great
that you committed
these crimes you have the right to be
informed of the nature of the charges
you have the right to a jury trial and
you have the right to manage to demand
and
receive a pull in our hearing within a
reasonable time to determine whether
probable cause
exists and if you're currently serving
in the united states armed forces or if
you're a veteran of such forces
you may be entitled to receive mental
health treatment substance use disorder
treatment
or other services as a veteran
sir do you understand those rights as
i've explained them to you this morning
i need you to answer out loud yeah okay
and for the record he answered
affirmatively
uh the people have filed a complaint and
information
uh charging 11 counts ms harold on
behalf of the defendant will you
acknowledge receipt of the complaint and
information
waive a formal reading and further
advisement yes your honor
all right we need to set this matter for
a hearing on uh
proof evidence presumption great along
with the preliminary hearing
uh what's the defense's uh thoughts with
respect to how soon we can set that
hearing
your honor we would be requesting at
this time that we actually set a status
prior to studying the proof evidence for
mentoring great hearing
our position is that we cannot do
anything until
we are able to fully assess mr alisa's
mental illness
we cannot begin to assess the nature and
depth of mr alisa's
mental illness until we have the
discovery from the government
my understanding that the government is
continuing to investigate this case
the discovery is going to be voluminous
and so at this juncture it doesn't make
sense to set the proof evident
presumption great here
it will be requesting a status
and so is your client willing to waive
his right to influence hearing within 35
days to accommodate that or
a later setting for preliminary hearing
and proof evidence presumption great
what's the people's position on the
request for a status in advance of a
proven nightmare thank you the people
have no objection i'll leave it to the
court's discretion
i will say the crime scene has not yet
been completed in terms of processing
we will be filing additional charges in
the next couple weeks
if people have not received any
discovery yet from law enforcement the
defense hasn't received any discovery so
that people have no objection to the
defendant's request
all right how far out were you
contemplating that status hearing
you're unrequited but i would ask three
months
okay um and you've discussed this with
your client he understands that he'll
continue to be held without bond
uh during that interceding three months
or so yes your honor all right so i'll
i'm sorry mr dory i'm sorry i do think
three months is further out than i
anticipated i would ask for at most a
month and a half i think that will give
us time to have
the crime scene processing completed
which i anticipate because the next
couple days
additional chores will be filed in the
next two weeks
and then uh council will have the
discovery evaluation well
so here's what i'm going to do first of
all grant the defendant's request to set
this matter for a status hearing
uh in advance of any setting for a
preliminary hearing or a proof of
presumption great hearing
i'm going to direct counsel to contact
the cja for division 13
to set that status conference i'll
authorize that status conference to be
set in about 60 to 90 days
i understand the concerns that you have
mr dougherty but at the same time
i want to make sure that the defense has
ample opportunity to prepare to move
forward
once we do set that hearing so contact
the cja for division 13. this case has
been assigned the division 13
chief judge ingrid bach he will be the
presiding judge in this matter
anything else at this time on behalf of
the people mr jordan
no yeah thank you anything else on
behalf of the defendant ms harold
your honor the government filed a
request to reconsider this court's
previous order with regards to
e6 right if the court is going to
entertain reconsidering that prior to
doing it we'd ask an
opportunity to reply i was going to
direct you to uh
uh to reply how much time do you need 14
days enough yes you're on a thing
okay so i'll give the defense 14 days to
respond to that motion i'll issue the
written odor in that regard
all right thank you we'll be in recess
thank god
thanks for using weather visit our
website at
[Music]
sorry
um as we move forward i'm going to
suggest the judge blocky that she taught
the council about ways to accommodate
people either in the courtroom or in a
different setting than just the general
webex
sure we have a different platform
available from the state we told me
about it yesterday afternoon and wasn't
comfortable trying to
initiate that this morning on this case
but i recognize that there are a number
of people who want to be president
so maybe talk between yourselves and
hearing's over